i got him
just gonna move your foot here
point your door this way
mind your elbow
[Music]
good job hawkeye
[Music]
where are my
i never had them
it worked
just like budapest all over again
you and i remember budapest very
differently
[Music]
you want me to slow him down sir
or are you sending in more guys for him
to beat up
i'll let you know
you better call it colson
cause i'm starting to root for this guy
guess i should have knocked
oh my god
what are you doing here disappointing my
kids
supposed to go water skiing
cab needs our help come on
clint can you get them off me
buckled in
yeah no i'm good i'm good arrow guy
let's go let's go
whatever it takes
we don't get that stone
billions of people stay dead
and i guess we both know it's got to be
i guess we do
[Music]
the city is flying we're fighting an
army of robots
and i have a bow and arrow none of this
makes sense
but i'm going back out there because of
my job
okay and i can't do my job and babysit
doesn't matter what you did
what you were
if you go out there you fight and you
fight to kill
stay in here you're good i'll send your
brother to come find you but if you step
out that door
you are an avenger
authorities are wondering if the masked
vigilante who terrorized the city's
underworld is back
when i wore this suit i made a whole lot
of enemies
you're a hawkeye who are you
some people have actually called me
the world's greatest archer
this is too dangerous
definitely not this one you don't have
to say definitely like that
there are arrows more dangerous than
that one
foreign